el gobierno venezolano sigue adoptando
medidas en busca de legitimar las
elecciones parlamentarias de diciembre
dentro según los anuncios del ministro
de exteriores- jorge arriaza informó que
hay el enviamos a antónio guterres ya
josep borrel una carta sobre las amplias
garantías electorales acordadas para la
venida a la elección parlamentaria así
como reiterando la invitación para que
naciones unidas y la unión europea
participen como observadores los
partidos opositores al gobierno habían
acordado no participar en dichos
comicios señalando un posible fraude
pero ahora un par de líderes contrarios
a maduro estarían buscando una
alternativa el gobierno de turquía
mencionó la existencia de un diálogo
entre el gobierno y la oposición en
cabeza del ex candidato presidencial
henrique capriles pero el presidente de
la asamblea nacional juan guaidó emitió
un comunicado en el que desconoce las
negociaciones que según dice se hicieron
a sus espaldas y a título personal
dejamos claro una vez más que estas
negociaciones emprendidas de manera
individual no representan y comprometen
en forma alguna a la asamblea nacional
el gobierno interino ni las fuerzas
democráticas
capriles respondió que gracias a sus
gestiones personales se siente
satisfecho de la libertad de los presos
políticos
refiriéndose al indulto que el gobierno
de maduro le otorgó a 110 personas entre
ellas algunos de los considerados presos
políticos pero entre quienes también hay
delincuentes comunes los opositores
aseguran que más que un indulto se trata
de una liberación de un secuestro pues
algunos de ellos no tenían procesos
judiciales